On the one hand,
of course, there is a certain level
of regulation involved, so of course I do
n't want any
robots to shoot at any people
or, um, that's clear or that's also
critical or that, for example, with
a serious diagnosis, a
doctor has to go over it again  Look before an
artificial intelligence says that it's this
or that, that's not a question for me,
but what do we do now before
the artificial intelligence is even there,
we're regulating in Europe again,
the Americans are developing it, the Chinese
are getting the data and we're
regulating  again and that's an
extremely dangerous bet that we're
making here because we're trying to
evaporate what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what what is
actually very important so again
the important things so especially the
critical topics yes the  should be
regulated I have just
given a few examples but you should let
it run its course.
Welcome to the OMR podcast today, a
guest who combines almost all of the variance that
we as a podcast want to identify
in his person, so an
incredible career in the
digital industry large companies small
companies American companies German
companies is a computer scientist himself but has
worked very naturally in sales and also simply entrepreneurially in
the group there is an incredible amount in it
and I think we now have a
bigger journey ahead of us I'm looking forward to
Achim Berg hello Achim  Hello Philip, hello,
so it's best to briefly introduce
yourself to me, you have so many
stations, which ones do you even mention
when people ask you, what have you
done, what else did I want to say? You
've already told so much, so
definitely those  I talk about all the professional topics
about German
Telekom, Microsoft Bertelsmann,
Dell, etc., the entire
industry, including Siemens. They always come
up and in the end
I'm always referred to as the Bitcoin
President. That was actually just a
hobby  It's actually just
a voluntary position, it's not a job at all, but for
the last six years I've
been introduced everywhere as BITCOM
President, but that's less than 10% of
my work. I have to say that, in my opinion, I'm a
board member and I'm also not a small
Microsoft Germany boss  yes and later
a whole pillar was
responsible worldwide so completely
led by Microsoft that was
also exciting and and then at
Telekom we were the TCom board of directors so
the fixed network board for marketing and
sales so also 30 40,000 employees
and now somehow you are still
saying that  Let's call a few
smaller things on the side flixbus
ride-on bike g so we've already been
guests at a priv equity investor where
you
worked or are, you can say no,
that's my main activity exactly
general Atlantic ah today no so today
exactly I still have  s reduced a bit now
and I'll do
something a bit different in the next one, you
'll try to figure it out right away but you wo
n't be able to but I'll stick
with yes okay but then then then let's go so far
59 so you almost have to
be around  to have done so much
but it really started with studying
computer science, yes I studied computer science,
that was really funny, um I
had back then, I wasn't the
best student now but I had a
reasonable standard of care but not so
good that I would have studied medicine
and then there used to be a
lottery process then I
applied for it and got the
place to study in Bonn and at the same time
a place to study computer science. I had
both places and I was
interested in both and then I
went to my family doctor and said
what should I do now  do I
have this or that he looked at me and
said study computer science because
you can really earn more money and then
I did GT okay then I study
computer science that was just a
coincidence in my career and
then how did it go after that then I
have  I studied computer
science in Cologne and
then joined Bull, a
computer company that has a very good
training program. The training program
basically lasted almost a year. We were
trained and now it has been
absorbed into Athos. It is a
French company, but of course we have
a lot  Learned a lot during that time, for
example the different cultures
that later benefited me, they
were French companies, I
worked for German Americans for Japanese and we
learned a lot about different cultures and procedures in
this training program, of course  also
other things but for me that was what
I really absorbed,
that the Japanese behave differently, that they never
actually say no but always say yes
but another yes and the
Americans are different and that it
was so easy to understand these cultures  Vital for me afterwards and
then you did that for a while there
somehow according to the program, yes the
trier program, I was with the company for 5 years,
by the way, that's
a typical pattern that I
actually always stayed with the company for 5 se years
because
You can always manage a zi year, but after 5
years you have to achieve a certain level of performance
and I always switched after about
5 years, not on purpose but after 5 years it
wasn't planned either,
but then I went from Bull to Dell and
Dell Computer was of course back then  the
RIS because that was possible Michael Dell I
also came over to Germany with Michael D
himself
I often picked him up at the airport
he really wanted to
drive fast. I was allowed to pick him up then
I drove on the motorway once
a little faster and was
really happy but of course that was
n't the main reason why you came
and I was at Dell for 5 years
and that was an extremely
important time for me, also for later because at
Dell everything is measured so Michael
always said you can  't manage what you
can't measure and that's what
you really learn with d
everything is measured is it really is
efficient it makes sense so this this
optimize this constant
optimize on the one hand I have
the ger on the  On the other hand, there was
also a
saying like constant
weighing doesn't make the pig fatter, so
you can't, you can't
check the sales figures three times a week and you have to do it somewhere in
a certain rhythm, but that
's incredibly strong  So to
concentrate on topics but
in the end it was a sales job, which means you
had to do this on the computer here in
Germany. Mark exactly, I was the
sales manager for medium-sized companies and
for dealer
sales. Funnily enough, Dell was very strong in direct sales,
but I also had dealer sales
He was also very strong, he was
even too strong afterwards, so I was
slowed down a bit, but
it was just about marketing the products
exactly and then you did that for
a few years, obviously
I also did it for F years, yes about F  Years
and then it went on again and then
I got the offer, um we remember
Fujitsu Siemens was Germany's
largest computer manufacturer and they were
looking for a managing director in Germany,
that was before the merger but I
already knew that they were merging with and fr
and I have that  I
also did it for a few years, of
course including mainframe computers, there was
of course the whole range and I
worked as a German managing director, which was the
largest area from Frit to Siemens and
then the corporate stuff came in
very strongly  as a
company and the Fujitsu colleagues who
were completely different, so I will
remember these meetings very fondly where
all the Japanese sat there
and in principle the boss was right at the front and
the least important one in quotation marks
sat further back and you have the boss
asked a question and the least important person
answered. That was the culture
that I had learned before and it was
often like that. Some of them are also in the
meeting, so we would say that they
fell asleep, but that's not entirely true. They
then close their eyes for a moment and
then lecture  You think, hey, for a moment,
he's still listening at all and that's it. He's
listening very well, but
it's a different culture, but that
was a very interesting time because for 10
years, at least in terms of the model,
it was just hardware  Sales in the
end a lot of hardware and
then with the mainframe computers it's
more about solutions so hardware and
solutions and then the change came. I
worked at the startup for a while, but that was for more
personal reasons, it was about one
Health question not mine but
in the family and then from
this one from Daus I went to Deutsche
Telekom directly to the board of directors
of Tkom so the fixed net tenants the
largest division in Germany who was the
head of Telekom at the time that was Joe Brauner
so Ron Sommer has  Hired me and
then I am but later Rick
took over and I did that
for 5 years. He basically
managed the entire landline lease for 5 years,
i.e. all sales, all
marketing, also the wood cell area, i.e.
the remarketers, this entire area
was in one hand  That was a very, very
big jump in sales, so how
much sales responsibility did you
have at Dell then you're always
sonon don't even talk about jumps anymore,
that's
more than jumps so there I went, of course it was
many billions
double-digit billions but was that
surprising for everyone
involved that someone or how much did
you do before, well,
of course I had a lot of experience in
this before, especially at fritu Siemens
with the Siemons Group
and then the fresh blood in this  to
bring in the Telekom also then
these and the approaches now sales
like how do I control the actual the
t points which products and stuff like that everything
is there
I probably convinced them in the
discussions and I've had it for a very long time
and I think it's quite good  I
introduced it, for example, that was an idea and
you learn a lot because when I
came, of course, there was a fight
between landlines and mobile phones. That was really
exciting because of course the landline operators
said we have to secure our landline network
and the mobile operators on the
other side  So t-Mobile has
this, what do these old landline users want
because they are dusty and actually it was
clear from the start that it
belongs together and I that was one of the
points I went
over to the other side very early very early
I met with Obermann and
Höttges
and discussed with them exactly
how we can actually do things together
and not against each other because
it was very clear that the landline
is regulated, which means that the minutes
or the market shares had to
decrease by definition, we had to each other  I'm
currently thinking about the DSL topic of
broadband. That was one thing that I
really pushed. Then I thought about it. It
can't be that this is actually
the actual call, so the
voiceicemen say that this is the future.
SN, you have to think about other things and
then we came  on the on the topic that
we have just introduced TV over over
over DSL in order to hold
this this now I'm
back in English but this
stickininess of
the of the landline network so
just broadband and something like that and the that
have  I also had a lot of discussions
with Obermann and hötkes. There was
always the very famous J fix Berg
hötkes where we met once a month
and that was really new,
that the areas were different and that was
from both Tim hötkes and
from  To me it was simply a sign
that we had to work together, even though
it was actually much less anchored in the minds of the
employees,
but when the leaders
get together, like many things in
life, we'll definitely learn
very intensively in other areas, and
that shines  from and actually it's
logical now HT all together there's
Telekom Germany that
runs both areas and that's
actually more logical. At the
beginning I was very active and very
intensive and then it went on
again after these famous 5 years
Yes, it's almost not that
you now think that after 5
years I have to change. I've been
with Ch Atlantic for almost 8 years now,
but
then I got an offer
from Microsoft
to head Microsoft Germany  Microsoft
Germany, of course, a great, attractive
employer, a great brand, a great reputation and
I thought about it for a long time and
then I thought, you know what, what are you doing
now and let's talk about the turnover that
microsof makes in Germany Z sizes okay,
yes, that's already it, so that
was back then  Also several billion already,
so Microsoft is also
big in Germany and by the way, that was
a week before I knew that Rene
Obermann would be the new CEO at Telekom.
If I had known, I
probably wouldn't have changed because you
got along well with him. Yes, I thought so  I
also found the type of
the modern management structure
very good and they are
still on friendly
terms but I then
changed and maybe
thank God and then I was at
Microsoft Germany W for three years  Just
briefly, all these changes when you
say I have received the offer,
then a
personnel consultant speaks to you. Yes, as a rule,
as a rule, someone
calls you
Interest there and for many things
you say no, it's okay, but when
something comes along where you think oh, that could be a
good fit then
I took it on and that was
a very important and very
interesting change for me and it also influenced me
I believe my life has been very,
very influenced by this
large corporation, Deutsche Telekom, with the
internal disputes with the politics that
you lead, also with the battles that are very
strong internally, so we
fought very hard with Tier online, a subsidiary over DSL, which
yes  It's complete nonsense because it's
a society, after all, that's what
you get there, of course, that
's very nerve-wracking, so
this policy but you also learn it and
then to come to the company in a
Microsoft that
is very sales-oriented
is very product-oriented, so Microsoft is a
company that lives very much from the product
and is made in the USA. Well, I'll get
to that in a moment. That was the
next step and then I
basically ended up at Microsoft Germany
and
then you learned about the experiences  One
thing I learned very well at Microsoft is
that the person is very important, so there
are very strong 36,360
reviews, so where you sit down there
is also a big meeting once a year,
usually with Steve Balmer
or earlier with Bill  Gates who then
where then really
go through the personnel planning for 90 minutes so
diversity topics range in the in
the personnel planning also then low
performers high performers and the low
performers doesn't mean that they
have to go out but how can I
support them how can I support them  put on other
positions, so this whole
discussion, the topic of how important
personnel is for success is
very pronounced at Microsoft and
I think that's one reason for its success
because Microsoft places a lot of value on it
and I'll get to that later  I have been
able to lead Germany for three years together with my team and
have a very strong team, for example the RAL
frup who was in my team is now
the European head of Microsoft, so he
was also my right hand,
we worked together and but
then it was  In principle, so that
we were very successful,
so Microsoft Germany wasn't doing
so well, so normally you do
n't bring in a new CEO or boss
when things are going well or
going badly, I think that's
I think I'm now  no news and
then it went really, really well,
what did you do to turn it around
so I when I when in this
case I really say we because we were
a team so a few things on the one
hand
the topic of communication we  We have,
I communicated very intensively
and communicated again and again and also
said if I didn't know something, for example,
then I also told the whole
team that we have a
problem here that we have to solve. I ca
n't tell you the result today, but
in  For four weeks I'll tell you to
really communicate consciously, to
keep this sovereignty over
communication, not to let the rumors spread
and that's one of
the key topics that I
advise every startup. Communication is immensely
important and not just once
but
say twice three times four times five times over and over again what do I want to do, where do
I want to go, set clear goals and
clearly set the direction for them - that's
immensely important and you always underestimate that - you
think, but I
told them and I have it at my
Microsoft  was that I
took a lot of time to
involve my closer management team and to invite an extended management team to
discuss openly but also to
discuss problems and the team, the
entire team and there were also
several thousand employees
inform what we do what we don't
do which direction we're running which
we're not running what I
essentially sold the
whole range at Microsoft back then that was all that was
Office
licenses what what come what what what what
advertiser the main driver is of course
the company there that  were the
enterprise agreements where we had
these complete agreements with the companies
about software, i.e.
operating systems, office systems
back then, that was also quite
interesting, maybe a second
learning that I always try
to pass on, um, it's so that you
can do that in the standard business  Yes, everyone, including
the sales department, does that, the
sales department drives the
standard products anyway, so an
enterprise agreement like it used to be called is
always sold and marketed anyway.
As a boss, I don't have to
say that just three times, but there are products
that  are very important in the future, for
example back then
cloudsices came up and is now called Azure,
but it was the cloudsices that
were marketed, it was at the very
beginning and it was totally clear to us that this
was the future and what I did then
Even though it
was a mini-sales and also a mini-profit,
I kept talking about these
cloudsices and drove the whole
company crazy, so I
over-focused on these cloud
services. Something funny happened.
We then went to America for this annual review
Then there were
all the countries with big boards
hung on the wall, the countries that
sold how many cloud services,
then there was Germany with almost
1000 contracts sold and the
second largest was the USA with
330, so you can only
imagine what was going on there
was you W but you were celebrated yes of
course but that was so that was
actually it's important when I notice
that a product will become very important in the future
I know but that I still have to do my
normal business with other products
anyway
Having the courage to focus on this new product as a
boss is what I'm
happy to pass on to every senior and every scaleup,
okay, and then because of the
success in Germany, at
some point you moved up to the US area, so to speak
Calls Steve Palalmer called me several
times a really but Steve
Bmer himself yes he does it himself
and then he called me the third time he
said I won't call you
again but because you didn't want to at first
yes I wasn't like that
I'm sure I said yes, there were a few
private issues and our son had
a few handicaps and I was
n't quite sure whether the American
school system could do that. In
fact, it's much better than the
German one  to come
and then we decided
to go over and I went to
Seel and then I went over to the in
this holy grail in the
product as corporate vice president so
one of the few non-Americans as
corporate vice president in  I
got into this product group and got to know Bill
Gates, of course, of
course, of course, okay, and so I got
to know Bill Gates several times. Bill Gates
is also next to Steve Balmer. Bill Gates
is an incredibly smart guy, so
scary.
I would have expected that.
I don't think that's news either
and I had him once in Berlin and
then he told me she was alone with him in the
car. We drove through Berlin and
he peppered me with questions.
I don't think I could answer a single one
about Microsoft. No to Berlin
about Germany and so on and so
on  what do I know and
gross national product and he wanted to
know everything, the bad thing was, he
noticed everything but then I
put up a brave fight and
maybe a story here on this
podcast that wasn't bad either. We
had Bill Gates invites
the 50 biggest once a year  CEOs come to their
homes, so the biggest names in the world,
the biggest ZOS, they usually come
and I don't know if they
still do it now and then we
went by ship to his house, which is
such a huge property, and his
employees  Because you were D as an
employee, but only a few of them and
I had the honor of being there too
and then I stood there and
discussed it. It was a nice
reception and we saw the library
and that's all I had
here  I don't want to go into detail at all,
but I'm very, very
impressed with where he lives in Zertel, on
this one at the seed dirt in Blackake
Washington and I came at some point
then went to the end and I had to
quickly go around the corner to the toilet  for a
short time and then I ran
there, it was pretty far and
no one is coming back anymore because everyone is gone, I think now
and I'm going to wait there, I saw the
ship leaving, she really
forgot about me and then I think oh, what do
I do now then I'll go like this  the
corner in the large living room there is
Steve Balmer Warren Buffett and
Robert
Murdock and me okay
and I come in there a bit
embarrassed and say sorry and B
also come here then they
probably questioned me for 20 minutes, the three of them
what is it like  Germany is running and
basically and all sorts of things that were
and then they're all much smaller
and look at me with their big glasses.
Unfortunately there haven't been any selfies yet.
I don't think I would have
dared to do that but I'd really like it and then
you'll have it later  Shift on it or
no no no then he did and then he
got me his driver and
then the driver took me to the hotel
since then I also know
where the actual entrance
to his house is but it's big for me
but that was that was a very
interesting story but that means
you have the time at mos USA
was also a huge learning curve
then yes of course first of all um
the Americans didn't wake up to the
smart Europeans that was in question in
ant that  That's how it is,
so you really have to push it through first, um for many
Americans, especially on the West Coast,
the world has passed the East Coast, so
I basically had to
show that the rest of the world
hadn't taken it on its head either
Of course, that was one at the beginning and don't forget that you do
n't speak the language like a
native speaker so you have to
enforce it. Microsoft makes it very
easy because they often try
to attract people from around the world to Seattle
They're also very successful in breaking it up. I'm
only there, so
in the first half of the year I
fought hard and then when I was accepted
it was good and it was fun too, how do you
have to imagine now, so you
were VP there and even corporate VP is
still there  sometimes others okay it's like
the top 30 or top 30 at Microsoft so
the top 50 I didn't
count them but so that was the biggest
order mhm and um then
of course you were also very involved in the
product strategy you had very so it
I had a lot of one-to-ones with
Steve Balmer, which were always very
funny and he's such a very
emotional guy,
actually very emotional, so the one-to-ones
that were scheduled to last 30 minutes
then lasted 90 and  He took
off his shoes and put his socks on the
table and so that was it, but it
was a lot of fun because
discussing with Steve B was a
lot of fun because he's incredibly quick in his
head and it's at the end  also a
sales person actually or that's he's
a full-fledged sales person yes and he also
has so he has also then he
also puts a lot of pressure but
in a I think in a very
respectful way so if you
know him personally and also funny
stories like that  he comes to Germany
and he also visited me here a few times
when I was still
running Microsoft Germany and then we
always went jogging in the morning,
so first of all he can see it's so
huge, that's exactly the point,
so he's big  and heavy and I
ran even more back then then he
just asks a question and the answer
takes z minutes so he can continue walking in peace
and I have to but the
funny thing is then
of course he comes out of the hotel with his security
and  Then instead of gloves he
put socks over his hands like a
multi-millionaire or billionaire and
then he ran over with the socks
then I said so be glove I
could actually
afford it okay but that's what
we did jogging really often
I often jogged with him and he is
also like a steam fold is called
very persistent but of course then
totally out of breath and um how long
was that in the USA then your Inter
so also three years so I was 3 years 3
years me  was in Germany for 3 years and
in the USA for 3 years and why did you
stop so then the decision came
when you That was a decision that
we made as a family when
you are out for 3 years when you
are abroad for 5 years is actually the way back
very difficult and we
thought about it: are we Europeans, are we
Americans, even if we
have a lot of friends in America, we are
Europeans from the heart, mhm, that's because
the culture here is ours, that we are also now
that everything is much smaller,
so now  Who knows,
you fly for two hours to Spain and all this time,
we had our house here, the
family and then we decided
we could go back, they just have to
give them the opportunity and then
that famous call came again asking
if I wasn't interested
Conversation with
Bertelsmann Thomas Rabe exactly and
the mon LM family was also there
and then I said that is definitely
an
opportunity that one can take into account
because then as the CEO of the
large part of the Berchels division
with over 80,000 employees wait what
exactly avato with many many tasks
is of course also something very attractive and
I thought about it with the family.
Interestingly, when
we went to America my
wife and son didn't want to go there when we
wanted to go back  not
going back so he
really liked it but common sense
prevailed we said okay we
're going back and you moved from siatttel to
Gütersl yeah half way so I
took my gutslo apartment but at the
weekend I was already in the  Cologne area
So I'm from the Cologne area
okay and I'm but for the week
I lived in Gütersl yes and W to
finish migrating the German economy,
you were then the successor of the
Rolf book exactly rol is now the boss
of vonovia too  a
DAX company and you have its successor
Avar undarto is the service division of
which you don't really know but the 80,000
people you just said sales 6 7
billion ah yes also many many
billions so now
I don't know the last last number but
it  were also clear, so we're talking
about more than 5 billion, yes, also
a large corporation, but something completely different.
We do call centers that
make everything possible, but that's
something different than Microsoft, yes, good, but
that's the question now and that  That's what
we're now slowly teaching ourselves about
the topic of what actually is management
or what do you do in management? Do I have to
understand every product in detail? For
some
I think it's important. For example, I think it's important that the CEO
of a company is the only one  who
can drive innovation because if he
has to recognize in principle
where the innovation goes where the
market goes it is very difficult to
delegate so I have to that's why
computer science wasn't a disadvantage for me because
in principle I W like it
how it works like it  Do
the topics now work in the same way as to
manage a company like an avat with
all the pillars? Because of
all the activities that I previously
learned with the team and all the activities beforehand,
you of course have a feeling for
what is important  what do you bring what do
you bring together where do you have to
let express messengers out where do you have to
protect areas where are the
innovations how can I bring something
together? Avato had the
special feature that there were actually 150 express
messengers that
drove in all directions and um I
also had in  Discussion with the family and
also with Thomas Rabe
then we thought about it, we actually have to
create five strong pillars for many
reasons for many reasons a can I
market the seeds differently a can
of course I leverage synergies
that sounds very simple and very
logical but in principle  Accommodating 150
companies in five pillars
with people who then also had
managers who also
did a good, very good job and
are doing a very good job, who of course also
lose a bit of their personal responsibility, was a very, very
hard job, let's say they should work and
probably print shops
I also take the printing company, which was already
relatively consolidated, which was already
together, but of course there were all these
logisticians, different
logisticians who had, um, then the
whole IT division, which was of course
also very large with
various areas that were
combined  Call center, um,
that was probably the
easiest because it's basically always the
same logic, um, and that was also
the largest area
Bringing the principle into logic
was my job, it wasn't an easy
task, it also cost me a lot of energy,
but it was also
probably one of the most important
and best jobs I
've done in my life, bringing it together in the
sense of value creation where you have the most
value of value creation but also
the energy it took. I
also noticed that you're always like that, you
always tend to think that I can
do everything, I do everything and I'm the great
manager and stuff like that, well that's also something you
have to do yourself sometimes  Listen to it,
I also noticed that I was
really struggling physically.
Now it wasn't not not
bad, but it was so that you
noticed that it was a
challenge to push such a big
bed, which really helped me  It was a lot of
fun but that was
certainly one of the biggest
challenges I had and then
it went on again then yes, that was
interesting and then there was the discussion about
extending the contract and then the
following came up, you really make a
big leap, I had myself  Before that I
had already spoken to Rene
Obermann a few times and
he had gone into his private equity
and at that time I was very
far away from private equity, venture
capital and large equity and all the
different topics and the like  I had
always said to me that you are actually
the perfect partner, also an operating
partner, to really
support companies and give added value
and I met with him a few times
and he had already explained it to me
a little bit and
made it palatable and I am  Then I got an
offer from General Atlantic
again, but that was
a coincidence anyway. I met a human resources consultant
at the airport in New York
who spoke to me and said they were looking
there and the job
description is actually accurate  what
I'm reading here in your CV
and then I had the
conversations in America, of
course I also spoke with Germans with Germany
Europe, so here the Jan
Nikolai colleague was, so to speak, is my
very close colleague with whom I
work very closely and  it's going out, no, yes, it's going
out, but it's going out
halfway, so now for now, but it's going out now, and so with Jörn
and with Christian Figel, who I
think you also know, I
worked very closely together  now 8 years and then in
principle this jump from the
active management of a company to
the somewhat
passive we support a passive
soundingbard which
would also be said in principle with the managing directors or the founders  I do it but
only really like that so do you have any hints to
give Thomas RAG Man knows what
Thomas I don't want to extend this any longer
GA that in my opinion yes that was a
combination so Thomas had some
ideas there were a few contractual
topics  I had and that's
fine for habag okay and that was
a big jump for me
into private equity and did
anyone tell me I said I was
in the Champions League for a bit
and D said no no no
No, private equity, that's the Champions
League. I didn't understand
that in principle, because it's
something different. Now I'm
basically called and the
companies ask me, you can
explain it to me, you can give me a tip
What do I do now for my
organization, what do I do with
governance issues, what do I
actually do, what do I focus on,
what do I want when it comes to product issues and such, to
have someone neutral in quotation marks who I
can ask questions on a regular basis, with whom I
can also exchange ideas? I believe that  That's
the art in the end, you're measured
by your two three investments that you
make, that's because in the other
job you probably have a lot of small
decisions or a
big strategy decision because
now the cloud business was at
Microsoft but somehow at PR
Equity is like that, everyone, you can
see very well what you bought it for
and what happened then, yes,
but that's ultimately it's
right, the exit will
of course be the most important event,
but if I take over a company then I
invest  Am I also
measured exactly every week, every month? How does
it grow? Is it the right strategy? Do we
continue to grow?
What's important is constant measurement,
I managed to develop the company further,
what were your biggest
investments there in the last few years?
Well, of course, I
joined Flix very early on. I think
Daniel was already here too.
I almost have Flix now  8 years
later as an advisory board member Aufatvors
could really be such a fund returner or yes,
of course, this is a company that
has developed really well but
where I was also very, very often and very
often, I think I was
probably one in the initial phase  Every day a
week I talked to Joche, Andrej,
Daniel and the team. I
tried to give my opinion,
but also a very important point. The
three of them don't run the company  The
chairman of the board sometimes
gives a clear statement, but the management team is actually
responsible for the business
and goes in.
It was probably worth several hundred
million or exactly that was
relatively small, it was worth several hundred
million and now we are
talking about clear ones  Billions of sums, yes, and
it was also after the railway, so there were
already some Corona at the beginning, so yes.
Corona was of course very difficult for
various reasons, but there was also
perhaps a learning lesson for everyone.
I won't forget the first meetings,
it started with Corona and
then there was a shutdown in Italy then
the management team came with a best
case scenario and a worst case
scenario. We did that every week
and in the second week I
said I have a good idea and we'll
turn the worst case scenario into the best
case  Scenario no, what actually and
it was exactly the right decision,
so we basically assumed
that these shutdowns and that the
shutdown of the business would be much more
brutal and faster
and you have to
make the decisions about the costs of personnel
and now there is that  But
then there were the contracts with the
partners and so on,
so the team reacted very quickly and very
consistently. I think
that was the case too  If you
notice that you are going in the
wrong direction or what is happening
then a company should
react very consistently and very quickly. How did
you get them? So they
simply pitched the investment to you
and you looked at it. Man, I
see myself as strong for that now  d
I want GA to go in or in
that case my colleagues had
already invested and I came in three months
after investing and the
first job I had was said
take care of it, that was the
first job I did  I had and a
few other investments from that time, of
course, of course, I have
one, we also have a nice exit, that was the
Control Expert, which was then sold to the
Allianzbmkt, that's what
we did, that's what I also
did with my colleagues, I'm sitting
still with stuff I think he's
already here on board there
also supports them very strongly so the
topic of go to market great company from
Kemnitz
so about a year ago I still remember
it was Christmas last yearb the
result is Martin
Böringer madness  So what S have built in K is
really great, so I'm
still very much part of Powercloud, which is
exactly what I did until recently. The teamv competitor is also really exciting,
like you normally
say, you're second  Yes, always the
first loser but in any case it's
not that good at all. Handdesk is a strong
product, it's quick and as a
computer scientist I think I can now assess that quite well,
so it's a great product that I
also really like and that also produces great numbers,
that's a bit of what it
is  These are the topics. I
also worked at PR 7 newcom for a while,
but later I
concentrated on other things and
these are the typical topics, yes,
and of course what I like to
do often is especially with them
when we scan the market and also
address companies that I'm also
there and say okay what like what do
I think of the management team what do
I think of the market what are the opportunities how
are they positioned what is the goto
market approach I'm asking now  one of
my infamous indiscreet questions
when in this journey did you actually
become an income earner
at at
Bull at Dell at Dell so because you had so
much sales no not at all that
was so sometimes there is also luck Dell
has developed incredibly and
there has always been  These stock options, there
weren't many, but I think the
Dell share price had increased by
10,000 times ago or something like that,
ah, okay, and then of course it happened at
some point, well, that's always on
paper, but then all of a sudden
I think, oops, something  That's what happened and Dell was
very, very successful from 95
to 2000 and the
salary level in the USA is different again.
If you then somehow go to Sel
then yes, but I have that now, that
wasn't the case for me  That's what it
was like for me when you're like that, when you're an
emissary, you usually stay
roughly within your own structure, okay,
but that was also completely okay, yes, good,
so for normal income changes
it's been at a
great level for many, many years,
but I think so too  a lot has moved, yes,
when you look at it in retrospect
you think oh God and now I would have
imagined that. I don't know at the beginning of
my career. Of course I
hope not. You can plan something like that. No, you can have goals. I think yes and
I was  Years ago, I was
an alumni at our school and I
really wasn't the best
student. That's something that becomes clear over time.
The teachers are getting better at
football, I'd say I'm only one
injury away from the Bundesliga,
so you're older  There's going to be a Bundesliga
next, that was really nice and
then someone then a large auditorium was
full and there was even the mirror there
because it was really relatively full and I
then told a bit about it,
I was Microsoft boss at the time and  Then
a very small 17
18 year old guy came up and looked
at me and said I have a question,
how can I have your job in 10 years, give me
the answer, I thought about it and
said that's a good question but
I think  There are probably three
things, one is I call it
leadership, I think you there are, you
not only have to know your your rights but also
your duties so the
work so this walk the talk what
the Americans say that in principle even
if I what  say then I'll do that
too and also a little bit of a little bit of
a bit of perseverance so I s there are
people now who say there's a
problem solve it so this
delegating back all the things so
I think that you always do a little bit
more than of  I
think that's how I describe it
with leadership and the second thing is that it
's actually my favorite topic, focus,
that you concentrate on one thing
and actually
finish it and not
have a new idea every three weeks, but consciously
stick with it or say the important thing
leads to the end this focus is
important s I that's a G more important
the third topic is m I call it
passion I've never seen
anyone be successful in their life
if they weren't for
something  so if I'm
not passionate about an idea or a job
then I won't
be successful and that also means for me
as a boss if I see an employee
who isn't passionate about what they do and does
n't bring that passion into it
then they have it  a wrong job or I
basically haven't motivated him that much yet
I think it's
this triad of
me focusing and working properly
also the topic of leadership and also
me um so I really notice
that I'm passionate about things and that
I can probably play back here
when I see the OMR that you all
built up, you didn't do that, you
got up every day in the morning, you
feel like changing something
otherwise you won't do it and that was
actually what I told him
I did  said what job that
is after that, it doesn't matter at all, but
it never bothered you about
not being an entrepreneur yourself, so to speak,
because I think that's what I get from time to time,
also reflected privately with
friends who also
say it's a great leadership position, man, yes  But
I would actually rather be a
company now or be
the owner of something myself, not never at all.
At the beginning, when
I was at school or when I was
a student, I think I sold 250 PCs,
that was a lot back then. I
opened up a small business
and...  I then assembled my students who
sold all the PCs and that used to be
done by hand, they were
still put together by hand, the boards
were put together and things like that
I
've now gone, which is also a
mixture of things. I don't know if you
can describe what
I've done in the last few years as a separate term, but
I think
I haven't regretted this path that I've taken for a
second and I even have three
If you were given tips, so to speak, you would say
that there were actually these ingredients
that made it possible for you to get into this
career, so or or there was
another formula that what
you do, there are a few things that
so luck is probably always luck
That's not a question at all,
but there are two other
things that I
've learned in my career that I
'm also happy to pass on. Ultimately,
you always have to question a business model, otherwise you can
cannibalize it yourself and that's very difficult  It's
difficult, so I don't want to
use the Kodak example or the Windows
Phone example, there are many
examples that didn't do exactly that,
but I ask myself the question
and that was often the case at Telekom,
so that I then
cannibalize myself too  in the landline business,
so what can I do with other topics
and this constant
thinking, am I still on the right
track, I have to adjust, I
also have to cannibalize myself, so
build up new topics, e.g. a sas model version on
premise, i.e. in the
software area or that  It's
very difficult for you because you initially
lose sales or maybe you
're not going in the right direction at Microsoft, with the cloudsices,
but knowing that it's the right
path and having that courage as a
manager and I think that's what distinguishes people
from weak managers  to have the courage
to question your decision, to
clearly express a wrong decision and then, in
principle, to make adjustments. These are
the strong managers of I have
the feeling that we don't know each other well, but
from what I can see a lot now
Building networks with people So you
just said in the preliminary interview,
well, the fact that
Ronaldo is invested in Chrono 24
is somehow also at the end.
You did another intro between
the KRONO people and Fernando Carro
Your successor at avato, the boss of
Bayer Leverkusen, is now
the same as the one there. It's
kind of a small world and you know how to
deal with people. Yes,
you build networks but you're not consciously aware of them. That's how
networks are created, for example, it
's very common  I that
of course you also please people or,
in principle, you also
have discussions, sometimes you have a conversation and it's not the same,
I know what stops your hand,
but you're also open sometimes, that's
a piece of it because I don't want to
give and take, of course
A network has also now developed through my
Bitcoin activity, which is probably also
clear. The association itself is
one of the largest and most
powerful or strongest associations in
Germany and is also very influential in
politics, although it
is not a lobbying association but that is of
course something you build yourself  In this way,
you build up networks and the
networks remain there even
if you change jobs or
leave the company. These are
very strong personal networks and
that is actually an advantage for
the companies that I work with  now
if there is a topic
then you can open a door here
or you can ask him
then of course you can do that too
and that's how it was with Chrono 24.
Jörn came to me and said yes  It would be
great if Ronaldo
was perhaps a enfan and a fetishist and
then I said you don't have any
contact there, I say I have to be a little more
authentic, I'm not the biggest
football fan but I think I know what to
do about it and then I
called Fernando  Fernando says of course
I know him and then it went like a charm and
then I made contact
so Fernando K has to say also a
stimulating figure like the boss he was looking for
as a successor, but he
's a Spaniard and I think he's at
Leverkusen, what do you call it  The president
isn't there from the managing
director so it's now you're now
expected to be out of
Leverkusen for a long time already
F years that's of course also someone
who also knows God in the world
is also very open in the football scene who
of course everyone in the football scene
I know that there was nothing closer than to
contact Fernando and then I did that
and he put me
in touch and then I
discussed it with Tim then
it went his way and then I didn't do
anything else  So
I don't want to have too many positive things about it,
but it was just
the coincidences that you have in life
and that certainly doesn't hurt if
you know one or the other, what's next
for you in the next few years, what do
you have planned  So
of course I'm still very intensively involved with General
Atlantic and also with the investments
we have. I've only reduced my working hours
a bit in the last year at General Atlantic
and
they've also taken part in that. You
said I don't want it at all
say it out loud again but of course I'm
not that old now but still and I'll
also do something very exciting
oh oh and that will
definitely interest you but I can tell
you now but is it an
economic or  a political
activity yes economically in
Germany yes okay oh so what what what
also has something to do with sustainability
and also with great challenge
entrepreneurship and I can
connect that with D but with General Atlantic
is because you never have any kind of reputation  to
go into politics somehow, to do something and to
somehow sort myself into it in some
form, yes, let's just wait a moment, let's not
go into politics, so of
course I have worked very intensively with politicians for the last six or even the
last 10 years and
also
had a lot of one-on-one conversations and so
We're also talking about Scholz,
Merkel and a
lot of them. I also have a lot of them.
I also have a lot of them
Politicians are also very happy when they
get feedback, also honest feedback,
and I have done that a lot, so I
am I would probably
fail terribly as a politician, why
the Army Laschad once told me that, so
you have no home power on the one
hand, you as a career changer  Maybe
we are also a touch too pragmatic,
which is difficult in politics, so
right now the topics that we are
all discussing
in Germany are causing a certain
dissatisfaction, which I
actually think is a shame because we
have a great country
Topics that we have just
discussed Focus on a few topics
clear communication also explain
explain what I'm doing um and
the whole over-focus on the
important topics for Germany that's
not exactly what's happening right now and you
ask yourself the question why not because
you're always willing to
compromise  That's the case
with the budget now and
most of the politicians I've
met are not
willing or able to make clear announcements. There
are real differences, so it was
exciting, especially in the past with Merkel or with Sch CL demisier  The conversations were always strenuously
demanding and I also have
the feeling that people were very well
prepared, but now it's a
bit too soft for me, so the conversations that
I had and I do
n't want to highlight any positive or negative ones here either,
I just think it's me  I would really
like that if we
order a tour we also get a tour
mm and that's missing a bit now,
a lot is happening behind closed
doors, a lot we
really have issues that we have to address,
the migration issue is on the
agenda, economy, energy, education  There are
really some really big topics, what
would I say as a federal banker, what would I say
if you were to spend a day there
yourself? A day would probably not be enough,
but what would you say?
What would a company manager do?
Doing what I just
described, he would say where are
the three biggest problems? That's
definitely the migration issue, that's definitely
the economy because without the economy there's
little going on, we don't have a
revenue problem, we have a spending
problem in Germany, so we
collect the highest tax refunds we
have  Yes, we have huge income, but when it comes to
expenses, we throw
money at the symptoms but we do
n't fight the cause and you can see that
now, especially when it comes to energy,
that we are now completely shooting ourselves out of
the market and also notice that
20  % of companies are currently
migrating abroad, which is of course large numbers and
also the topic of bureaucratization. We
now have
100,000 people in the public sector every year,
more than 5.5 million employees and
I think I have the numbers right
in my head. In 2012 we had approx
9 billion in personnel costs and last
year we had 36 billion in
personnel costs in the public service,
we are building up an incredible amount and
all of these topics now I would
say I'm concentrating
on two or three and would
really
push them forward as Chancellor which topics  Are
you here now
maybe everyone sees it differently but
I would like people to say okay there
are these three four topics and when I see
our federal ministers and I
was allowed to accompany them um then
I see that they are from one
Jump to the other stage and they're
completely sealed off but they're spinning
in circles somewhere at the speed of light
where I ca
n't, basically how can I really concentrate now as
a company manager
when
I'm being watched by another camera every 20 minutes
and I think
I would sit down to clearly define the goals and really move forward,
and that's not
that easy in politics. Mhm, if
you were 20 again, you would
study the same thing in Germany  and so yes, I would
study the same thing, I would also study it in
Germany, I would also
stay in computer science,
maybe more in the direction of artificial
intelligence, but that was already the case for me. There was
fasilogik, so even
30 years ago we were already
discussing AI and that  The logic is the same,
so you would focus your career
on Germany again. I would
say, I
would study in Germany,
maybe a few semesters abroad,
but I would stay in computer science,
maybe now because it suits me because
I am also me
I'm also interested in technology, I'm also a bit of a
geek. I also have any technical
news, I try it out
and work on it. I still write
one or two programs when I can, but
a little less recently
but just in this topic I
would do the same thing again because I
learned or I also
learned in my professional life even
if I did completely different things
like you just said if you
have a basis for how
data processing actually works and how computer science
works  Digitization helps
you with every topic because you
basically know how data is stored, you know
how computers work, you know how
programs are written, you know
how user interfaces are built, and
that's a very different
feeling when talking about it  what is
important because digitalization is
immensely important because you are now a
correspondingly big
ai say fan, you can't be a fan but or
you can say bad but so
full of expectation that this will
completely change everything in the next few years,
yes it will  So they also change what
you can already see, these LMMS, these
large language models that are now
being used, they are
incredibly powerful and because
of the logic, if you deal with the
logic, how they
only work because of them  Computing power is coming
and it's not possible, it's also a
sustainability issue, but I
've already
created pictures with journey and that's
incredible, it's a lot of fun,
but there's no business model
yet, but there are already
business models  So I can, for example,
I can of course build advertising photos
with journey, of course, but these
are small ones and
but the actual business model to
perhaps include that is
companies like the large
automobile manufacturers or the large
telcos that have an incredible amount of
information  Let's say we all have
all the manuals from the
automobile manufacturers for the
various cars of the last 30 years.
If they are all read in principle
and a special LMM
is built, I can ask any question in the world. This
LMM can tell me this one
Chatbot can
basically answer any question much better
than any specialist and I
believe that in this direction
companies can optimize themselves and also
improve quality.
I don't think that's a question at all,
most companies have been working
on it for a long time and that  will change a lot,
but now we're
back to a certain extent in politics on
the one hand, of course there's a
certain amount of regulation involved, so of course I do
n't want any
robots to shoot at any people
or, um, that's clear or that's
critical  or that, for example, with
a serious diagnosis, a doctor takes
another look at it before an artificial
intelligence says it's this or
that, that's not a question for me,
but what do we do now before the artificial
intelligence is even there, do
we regulate it  Europe is developing again, the
Americans are developing, the Chinese are getting
the data and we are
regulating again and that's a
dangerous bet that we're
making here because we're trying to
evaporate what what what what they what what
Actually, what's very important is
the important things, especially the
critical issues, yes, they should be
regulated, I just
gave a few examples, but you should let
it run its course and we
lack data anyway, especially in
Germany, so we have, for example
Corona pandemic we bought 3 million
data sets abroad to
understand Corona even though we
have all the data ourselves but we are
not allowed to use it, these were topics
that you can't actually understand
and we are making the same mistakes with AI
again we are leaving again
I
have the feeling that
you missed it, as an
investment Alf Alpha you could
probably have been there as a G,
so first of all we  We get annoyed
about every investment that we've missed
out on and that's
certainly part of it, but you're always
smart afterwards, like the
lottery numbers. W doesn't know beforehand,
but he now seems to have a certain
closeness to Mr. Habbeck and that
It seems somehow that they are already
talking about what Germany
is doing now, at least that's how I take it to be true, so
there is already proximity, so Habbeck
and those around him are already opening up about this topic of AI and are
looking for you and are thinking together about how
we have to do it  So not only
Habbeck but also
the Interior Minister and the entire
public sector are working very
intensively with artificial intelligence and also
like the federal government, the federal and
state governments also have a common
platform. There is a very interesting platform
that has been built, that is the
gftech  The campus here in Berlin is
where people basically think very intensively about the
topic of artificial intelligence and atz in
the public sector, so there
are already a whole range of areas that
are going in a good direction.
Speed ​​is something you always want,
especially in Germany  There are
some things that are happening in a very positive way and
I think we can also address issues
like we all remember the
property tax to which the property tax which
we all had to hand in West
most of us and where I asked myself the question
the apartment or houses
They have to own apartments, houses,
land and then I asked myself the
question, of course I have that too
and I looked at it
and every piece of information that was asked of me is
already there,
it's in some cadastre of
an authority, why do they want to know that from
me  They have all the
information and then I really ask myself
the question, why haven't they
put it all together and maybe put it together
again for a final vote that
every day here is all your
information, which is right,
which you are now looking at in front of
Background of your experience in the USA
and these various corporations
on the platform Germany if you
put it like that as a platform um
in the end a country like that is nothing
other than an
organization somewhere a very big um positive
for the next few years or you  you're
very skeptical, how do you see that? So
deep down in my heart I'm rather
skeptical, um, I'm, um, I'm, I really
enjoy living in Germany and I have
absolutely no idea of
ever leaving here. I think we have
a great country too  with where we are also
allowed to say things to the freedom and we
have many, many things that we
have worked out, I am a bit, um,
nervous when I see the topic of education.
Well, I didn't start the PiS study,
but also how we
approach the topic of digitalization, um  I
also believe that it is
precisely the school leavers in our
school system that was praised somewhere for many
years, but when I
now see that 43% of primary school students
cannot read properly after leaving school,
that in principle we also have many
who cannot speak German properly, which, by the
way, is not possible  The migration problem is, and
also partly in German
families, the fact that we
have 50,000 people leaving school without a
school leaving certificate, that a lot of universities are
dropping out and so there is something fishy about it
and I think that
addressing this issue, including
how we fared in the corona pandemic,
was basically
just that  The schools and the teachers
who were involved in the Prinip
continued it and we are
now in Pisa this crash, which
I think is due to the pandemic, is
completely wrong because we had that
was one of the projects that I pushed very hard
This digital part was a
school with these five billion. I was
incredibly committed to it. I
wrote to every state minister. I was
a bitcom boss at the time
because it was really important to me,
the topic of education, that's ours
and that's what Germany actually is
But we don't have a small amount of
raw materials, especially our
engineers and computer scientists, and I
wrote to everyone and we made these
5 billion available and
then I noticed that they weren't
being used at all and I think it was
only 1.5 in the end  Billions or
less than z Jen have been accessed then
you ask yourself the question, why is that
because all schools look for
IT equipment and look for a
modern structure and no one accesses it
and then I looked into it and
then saw that they were
The demands on the schools
were infinitely high. There were over 80 pages that
had to be filled out. A
media plan had to be drawn up.
Evidence had to be provided. Then it wasn't
entirely clear what actually happened to the
iPads or
pads that I had purchased  W is
actually watching and and and so we
met again with that we had a
great idea and then it
completely collapsed in the whole federalism
and that's of course really
what was very very frustrating for me
so um now we have
Understood, you would
focus on certain topics, so to speak, but B would be
rather
skeptical about the Germany platform
due to educational topics, but at least these are
things that you have control over yourself,
that's somehow something that could be
changed, i.e. the general tectonics
to be crushed, so to speak, between the
USA and
and
China, these big
geostrategic questions that do
n't bother us so much, in the end we
are a relatively small market in terms of people in
comparison, it doesn't put a strain on it, it's
not that bad if you just have the
right products V  vonem nohau
can now build a broad
question again but first of all I see not
only Germany but also the EU and I
believe that W in the EU
can set the impulses with Germany as the third
or fourth largest economic power in the
world but also the largest in Europe, i.e.
us  could provide significantly more impetus in the EU, which is
why
Germany's constant abstention from the
EU Commission really annoys me because we simply
can't have an opinion on many things
because the parties involved can't
agree. I think that's exactly
the topic I'm talking about  I do
n't have this focus on clear
topics. I think that Europe
would do well to behave neutrally and not
move too much in one direction or the other  There is a
strong demand to withdraw a little from
China's dependency,
but that doesn't work any more
than the USA, so W the dependency is not so
global dependencies, so you
think you can maintain this neutrality
and not be
forced to
go to camp in any way  So
you can maintain neutrality plus, of
course, you have to create resilience
in important areas and that's
what's currently being discussed, for example, with the chips
that are now going to be produced here in Germany,
and many other
topics that I say are needed  I
just hau, um, whether it's
medication, whether it's energy supply,
um, then I have to make sure that
I don't open myself up to blackmail in
certain areas, that won't
work everywhere, but I can say that I
'm actually a fan of it anyway
Neutrality and the strength to
concentrate on yourself.
Don't you still laugh a
little bit broken somewhere in the USA about
the companies we are building here because you
now know Microsoft, they are
now worth trillions or something like that,
yes I think more than two
something  I mean, we're now talking about
companies that we're proud of, rightly so
in Flixbus, and they
might do an IPO next
with say 3 4 5 billion, I
don't know anything in that area, it's just
so far away  that you
ask yourself where the rating is so you are
there you are not so far behind in the rating that
you
can actually never catch up again I think you are
underestimating one thing that is our
medium-sized companies um how many how many
hundreds of world market leaders we
have in Germany with  great products
and all in all they are a power
mhm so when you mention a flixbus
I don't know market leaders in 26 countries
um these are now more the
newer companies but also many of
our classic market leaders um or
companies that we have in mland are
very  very strong worldwide and uh
of course they need young people they
need skilled workers we have over
630,000 skilled workers who we are missing
140,000 in computer science that's that
I come to my topic of education and
how I can do that we have a
very rigid working time law uh I
have to  In principle always I can only
think I don't know I work 11 hours a day
we have a day so that's when
I have to take a break for x hours why do
n't we have a weekly rule none
because now it does
n't make any sense at all in that time  I
like to check my
emails in the evening or early in the morning and then maybe
I'll take my children to
daycare and then I'll continue working,
but we have them that are very
inflexible in many areas, but
I think that we are very inflexible in Europe  probably
have a chance and I hope that we
have a chance
with what we have with what we
have, but at the moment we are
very busy with ourselves, um, and we have the
issues that are all on the
table right here, also with internal ones
Security and everything that goes with it, um
I think politics can
support us, but actually the
most important thing we have is the
economy and I don't
always want to look at politics,
politics has to create the framework conditions
for us to be successful,
that means  We have to have a reasonable
data
protection framework in data
we need energy issues we
also need clear regulations for startups because
we also have a lot of really good
startups that also
belong in the market there
are probably thousands of topics but
that  I think it's going beyond the
scope here. Have you
ever thought about it? No,
I've always kept myself neutral in this area,
except for the extreme
right and left
keep it and
now let it be known
that you are now involved in the
sustainability industry,
that
what could that be, yes, that's exactly
the question, no, I have, I'll put it like that,
so there are some
challenges, nice challenges
in Germany too and it  There is a very
interesting project or very
interesting projects
that I would like to
work on and that is exactly one
of them and that fits very well with
my current activities and fits well
with my CV and I promise
I would have typed a CV
if you had  If you hadn't said that about sustainability,
I would have been okay, you're
now going to too black or to Lidl because
they want to make a big attack
in the area of ​​cloud and cyber
security and that's a huge topic
that people are following from afar  That
would have actually been that I would have now
that would have suited you now
as well as the next
big German growth project with
a lot of capital but that's
not obvious
you bring a very good point that
of course it's not obvious otherwise
I would have now  probably
nodded but what what what Lidl or what
black in Halbronn is doing, I can
only recommend that everyone take a look at it, it
's really impressive that the
universities 42 this this this Code
University was built is now the
topic of artificial intelligence what he's doing
but also in the group  yourself the the
topic cloudsices that is really very
impressive so you
already know each other and you have it you're already there
of course I'm there with that with that with that with that with
the 42 so this
this this Code University I'm
also on the advisory board  yes okay okay but the
okay ke vi vi also a very funny
story while we're at it, we were
once sitting at a
table like this and six eight
people, we then introduced it and then
everyone presented what they were
doing  Then an older gentleman came along and
said hello, my name is
weak, I'm a
single person, I didn't know him
before, but I thought that was so cool,
okay, so the impression was
a little more modest than
Begg, yes, that was very  Well, that was, he's
almost on Bill Gates level, no,
what he's so very impressive about, he's totally down-
to-earth and I
had conversations with him before
and that was just very
refreshing and he's
not  The youngest, he's also a
little older, he knows, but he's the
one who's still active, he
's still there, he's very
interested in it, yes, and then
at some point he withdraws, but he
's not there yet and he's doing it
Things are also very active and he also has a very
clear opinion on them and that's really
very impressive so we have you
have you have for in the preliminary conversation I know
Elon Musk I don't know that's the
opposite that's of course but
imagine Elon Musk without without
his whole thing around it and his then
drumming the whole topic and he is
basically exactly the opposite he
just does but is because your view now
of someone like Elon Musk is
now more positive or he negatives
so that is his performance  The
bottom line is that what remains is that there is
somehow a positive rating on Elon
mask or or a negative one. On the
one hand, I admire his courage and
his willingness to take risks and I have that. I
said earlier that courage and willingness
to take risks characterize a
strong manager. On the other
hand, I am  I'm often irritated by
his statements and also his topics and
his erraticness in
some areas that irritate me a bit,
so
it's probably like many great
personalities including Apple and Apple
founder and W also Bill Gates who is
also a special one  Humans are completely
different than Musk,
I have the feeling that it has changed a lot, so Bill
Gates was the same back then. I
think it must have been at the time
when you were there in
Germany, very much like the dark power  It
's a very difficult guy,
so much so that he's also a pure capitalist, the
richest man in the world, all negative and
now when you see how he's
developed as a person then
suddenly he gives a lot of money to issues and
donates an incredible amount  It goes into
trying to
tackle the really big issues, delving
into the issues with incredible intellectual depth
and you really get the
feeling that he really wants to do good things
for the world and that from a
distance of course now seems very
credible, so I always have it  The
feeling has changed a lot, he has
n't changed at all. Zero, okay,
he's always been like that, he's just been pushed down by the
population or by the
media. The richest
man in the world, oh God, what is he doing here,
what is he doing there  I've known him
personally since 2007. I
met him for the first time at the beginning of 2007 and he
always had this
philanthropic attitude. He always
said I would completely save my fortune.
I still remember in 2007 we
drove through Berlin and then we had
German ones  Visited foundations or something
and the German Foundation
met with Bill Gates and he
asked me, completely irritated, but they do
n't spend any money at all, they
just keep the money and give
out a little, but they have to
spend it all, that is  But I don't understand now
because he said I'm taking
all of my assets from a foundation
and the foundation keeps reducing,
so that means he has a
completely different approach, that was
15 years ago, so he's always been like that
a bit of a nerd
in the nature of things is extremely
intelligent I don't think I
even need to mention that here but do you
still have contact with and so
I haven't had any contact
with Steve Balmer for years, I still have him
but with Bill  I still have Gates
because every now and then there are questions about
Germany and you help with that. Then
he writes to me on
LinkedIn and asks something or yes, yes, that
's it, so he's also
very bookish and then  When I'm
on the west coast,
I sometimes write to him and say,
are you there right now? But he's mostly
out and about, but now, above
all,
basketball is exactly where he's active now
and then he stands on the sidelines just as
euphoric as he is  to the best Microsoft
event, but
I'm still in contact with him now,
but you couldn't come back to Elon Musk
in the same way that he's
seen in a more negative way now, where he has this role, so to speak, as the
richest man in the world or  It
's also a bit of a media phenomenon
or are you saying there's really something fishy there?
I can't tell you that. I
don't know him personally
uses a lot of political communication and Bill
Gates never did that, so
he never did political communication, he
only spoke about malaria or other
topics to combat that. I
mean, there was a very interesting
meeting. There were almost 5,000
people there  Room at that big
event and Bill Gates was
talking about malaria and then he had
a big glass jar somewhere and he
opened it and said I'm
going to let a malaria fly out in
that room and then 5000 people
sat in the hall like frozen, of
course  no malaria mosquito but it
was there he got the
attention okay are those
somewhere too so that's also part of the art
we haven't talked about it yet
so at mas we just
wrote your stories to you and
constantly develop them further whether they're good
or bad  od are helpful but
a certain storytelling is
not part of the CEO or leadership,
you haven't
talked about it at all, actually, that's
actually a point that I also
think is very important, do good things and talk about it,
of course it gives up  On the one hand,
people who
build themselves up incredibly well, but if I have good
ideas, I
also have to
market myself in a certain way and that
's internally and externally, so if
I have good ideas and have successes  then
I can also show you and tell you
and of course we also have some
black doesn't do that at all, he does
n't do that at all, he just acted,
he just did it,
probably that's so the this
this classic old
the old you would  today a
modern younger say a founder who is
now or grown up somehow where there
could now be g in the size
or someone who doesn't know now
needs your advice who is now in his 30s 40s
somewhere then I would say go to
link in be present there tell  your
story go out, I would
definitely tell the story on
LinkedIn is a prime example of this
or even here in this podcast to
say what you do, I think it's
very important, it's
essential that the companies also do
theirs well  well transport them not only
internally but externally
I think CEO has to be a
prime example to the outside world Tim hötkes who also has
a lot of power on the outside who also has a
lot of personal power and I think that's also
an important point I have to
do it myself I can
I don't have to delegate the topic of LinkedIn. I have to
sit down myself. That was also a learning experience
for me. I always wrote my LinkedIn posts
myself, every single one
until the end because that's more authentic, it's more
credible. The
smooth ones are always difficult
and that's why when I do it  I
personally stand up and there is
definitely one or two founders who
I like to be on stage but there
are also other options like
social media like other areas but
I it's good for the companies all
strong companies and we have
some in there  Thank God there are also
some good startups in Germany that they
really show their courage and say what they
can do. I think it's very important and
at the same time sometimes the feeling is that Link is
full of coaches and
all sorts of sales stuff and you
really feel comfortable there now  Actually, it does
n't really matter either, so I mean, I
'm now
saying a lot about what's happening now, but you say why and then you have to
change over to it, yes, what
do you mean, where else
?  Due to my
activities, I don't often write
something, but when I have something to say,
I write it and then I notice
that there is a lot of response, then there is
also a lot of reading, a lot of
feedback comes, people get
it, so that's it  You have a
certain presence if I, of course,
say something every other day that
no one wants to know, so I should
n't be surprised, but I think
if there's something to be said and it
's done sensibly and comes from a personal perspective,
LinkedIn is also a good
platform  Someone
like you has probably been active for a long time now, so you
'll be doing it every year for the next 5 se 10 years.
The normal
retirement age is 67. Then you say
that my professional life is
over or what is your
perspective on the next few years? There are
two
more answers  than two, the one answer
is as long as you're fit and having fun, you get
on with things, but there comes
a point where you have the feeling, and I
said it so well with the one at BITCOM, I don't have the last one at BITCOM
Sit in a row or
sneak around the buffet and say clever things
so at some point the point
comes where you have to say okay, I
now have my my my topic we
achieved everything that I wanted to achieve I
have to let go and I would no longer be
cramping somewhere
I would
do that and I also believe that in the
next few years I
can still give some impetus or whether you
can pass on experience. I also
think it is a task for the older
generation. I hardly dare to
say older, but for the older generation  because
I still have a lot of hobbies and I enjoy it
and I'm also very active but the
older generation wants
to pass on the learnings, at least that
the youth or the young
company leaders or company
managers can in principle
not absorb information or or or or knowledge
what  What you do with it is
a different topic, but it sounds as
if you would soon be on
another council or advisory board,
so I have a few
advisory boards and advisory boards that I still
do, I'm also on some of them now
and so are they  I'm very active,
I still enjoy it and as long as I enjoy it,
I'll do it, but I wo
n't sit here at 84 and
hold on. The black would
do that, the W would do it, yes, there is a
crucial difference that you have
at the beginning  you asked me,
would you rather be self-employed as a
self-employed person? I can understand that well.
As a self-employed person you build something, you
manage it and give it
into your own hands. You are there as a consultant. I don't know about Dieter Schwarz. In your
own hands you can do that  I don't think
so, I don't think he has
the successor for it now,
but I can very well understand
that you want to be involved somewhere in this company for a long time,
as an employee, at
some point you have yours
Work is done then you go and then
you leave the company
alone, what do you do privately for
investment? Well,
because I'm in private
equity, my hands are pretty much
tied.
I have so much time  I've made a few angel
investments on a small scale but
otherwise I stick to ETFs or
real estate or I'm allowed to have ETFs and
real estate ETFs that are a bit broadly
diversified but now nothing
in any way where you say okay wow
nothing crazy NS nothing special I
'm rather conservative  and
just try to make sure that
what you have built
somehow lasts for a while,
everything is clear, yes, I think the
promised tour has been completed
or has been completed, I hope or
probably we have
at least discussed a lot of things, probably
not everything, yes  It's easy, I don't know
you, actually, you know
Steve Barmer's legendary video,
I just didn't dare to ask,
what was it like when it's like that, so
of course it's like that, that's exactly what it was like
when she was on stage and I was
standing there  in the front row, he's
really like that, it's
not an act, he's
like that, he's so euphoric that
he really is, that's what he thinks,
I don't know what's playing in his body,
but he is  then really out of
control that's I've
experienced that a few times, it's totally
refreshing, but he's a
sales person and he's
probably the best sales person you
can imagine, no, so he's a
sales person in a positive
sense  has an uncanny feeling for
the customer he also knows what is happening he
also knows what products
need to be built this breadth as
not just the classic sales person
but the holistic sales person
that is a a a a a a miracle
his memory is
unbelievable  well, he still knows now
what he
did somewhere in March, so he has a
memory that's simply
unbearable, it's really embarrassing sometimes
than as a conversation partner,
well, all right, so I just wanted to
say briefly that there is  There are many more
topics that we can talk about, but let's talk about it
first, maybe there will be
a second one. I think there's
a lot to offer. First of all,
thank you very much for coming,
thank you very much, all clear ciao
[music]
ciao